so yesterday we got a look at some
unused concept art from Avengers
infinity war these photos showed us some
alternate designs for the iron spider
costume a different look at Captain
America and a few different looks at
Thor
well these photos were actually leaked
from the Marvel's Avengers infinity war
the art of the movie hardcover book you
can buy the book in just a few days it
comes out in November 6th but until then
it seems like somebody has managed to
get their hands on a copy and has leaked
some more photos from it and one photo
in particular shows a either deleted
scene from Avengers infinity war or a
possible new scene that could be in
Avengers 4 I'm still giving away copies
of infinity war Deadpool 2 and ant-man
and the wasp as well as some special
edition posters if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
some of these photos aren't really
anything different than what we saw in
the movie as you can see in these two
photos right here of Thanos getting the
space stone this scene pretty much
played out exactly how it looks in the
movie the only tiny difference being
where Thor and Loki are positioned then
we have this picture of Bucky and he
pretty much looks exactly the same as he
does in the movie the only difference
obviously being the hair he has much
longer hair in the movie and his
vibranium arm actually has some gold in
it in the movie then we have a couple of
more pictures here of Thanos and the
black border on Thor ship again the
scenes in the movie pretty much played
out the same way that these concept art
photos are designed with the exception
that Thanos is actually grabbing four by
the throat here and not putting the
gauntlet to his head using the Power
Stone and I'm glad they decided to go
the other way in the movie because I
thought it was a great way to start off
kind of using the Infinity Gauntlet and
then in this other photo we have Evan
EEMA bowing in front of Thanos to give
him the tesseract which of course is the
space stone again only difference
positioning of Thor and Loki at this
point in time evany mile will have taken
all that scrap metal and would have
bound Thor down and covered his mouth
and again I'm glad they went that route
in the movie because I think it played
out better these photos of Iron Man and
Captain America here are pretty much
exactly how they look in the movies but
if we take a look at these two photos of
Captain America they are very different
from what we saw in infinity war so
they're clearly going for nomad Captain
America in these photos so in infinity
war Captain America really isn't Captain
America Steve Rogers sort of dropped the
mantle after the events of Civil War he
had no star on his chest the whole
entire time throughout infinity war and
before infinity war we know that he was
going around doing secret missions so
this look is kind of a special ops look
but ultimately they decided to keep him
in the Captain America outfit just take
away the star this next photo is really
awesome because it's several photos of
what the iron spider suit could have
been so the photo on the right the red
and gold iron spider armor that's
actually comic accurate so that's their
base that's what they took their
inspiration from and made all of these
other designs and ultimately led to the
iron spider suit that we saw in Avengers
infinity war which wasn't totally
different than the original comic
accurate suit they just added a ton of
more blue into it and slightly changed
the logo design so sticking on Spidey
this next photo is very intriguing this
is actually a scene that we never saw in
Avengers infinity war as you can see
here spider-man is actually fighting
Thanos his outriders this is clearly a
scene that was left out of the fight
between evany MOC coal obsidian iron man
banner
Doctor Strange Wong and Spidey this is
clearly after ebony mom made Doctor
Strange go unconscious so what most
likely happened what they were planning
on doing is that Spidey actually ends up
rescuing Doctor Strange as you can see
here he's all webbed up in this scene
that they had in mind that they actually
didn't do they could have had Wong play
a bigger role in the fight he could be
fighting ebony ma while iron man is
fighting coal obsidian and since Eponine
ma was in the middle of a fight he could
have sent the outriders to go and get
Doctor Strange and fight spider-man now
I've heard online already that some
people think that this could be a scene
from Avengers 4 it's not very likely so
I don't think so this is just I'll call
it a deleted scene a scene that they
decided to not use in the movie now they
could go back in time and Avengers
to this particular scene and prevent dr.
strange and the time stone from being
captured and prevents spider-man and
Iron Man from going on a Bini mashup if
they prevented that from happening then
they could have Doctor Strange Wong Iron
Man and spider-man regroup with the rest
of the Avengers in Wakanda but again
even though this makes sense I don't
think it'll happen this is an infinity
war art book so I don't think they're
gonna give much for Avengers 4 if
anything in this book and then the last
photo which is actually the back of the
book is a tribute to all of the heroes
that we lost in Avengers infinity war so
that's it from all the leaked photos
that we got from the Avengers infinity
war art book again you can buy this book
in just a few days on November 6th but
let me know what you thought about the
photos and what you thought about the
scene with spider-man and the outriders
do you think we could see this in
Avengers 4 or do you simply think that
this is just a scene that we never saw
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]